hey guys it is Thursday my name is Jeff
I'm Dan and you're watching guess what
news have a cursor a co button so this
story actually happened yesterday but
for some reason and didn't think it was
the most exciting thing in the entire
world like I do but a finding paradise
the next game indie to the moon series
finally has a release date at a trailer
doesn't have any reload animation
sitacles the new trailer kicks off with
a parody trailer for to the moon
- which teases more explosions and loot
boxes than the original it also
addresses fan concerns from people who
played the first game that space
shuttles in fact do not go to the moon
the trailer wraps with an actual game
trailer for finding paradise the second
full episode ended to the moon series
from developer Freebird even more
excitingly we finally have a release
date for finding paradise and it's not
far off the game will hit PC and Mac on
December 14th so mark your calendars
much like the first game finding
paradise will follow two doctors
venturing into the mind of a dying
patient and attempting to reconstruct
memories from within to satisfy the
patient's unfulfilled lifelong wish if
you haven't played to the moon it's 75%
off on Steam right now so go pick it up
those of you who loved being a digital
tourist down and up in Forza horizon 3
will be stoked to hear that the studio
playground games is working on an
open-world RPG they are and they've
brought on some pretty sweet talent to
help them out according to games
industry top is playground games has
secured a new 200 person office that
they'll use to house the team that will
work on their new non racing game some
of the talent joining the English studio
have worked on games like Metal Gear
Solid 5 the phantom pain Grand Theft
Auto 5 and hell BladeCenter with
sacrifice there's no concrete details on
what the game is aside from it being an
open-world action RPG which if it's as
good as foot to Horizon 3 will be
delightful see your Gavin Rabin told
games industry top is that the project
is hugely exciting and that quote the
combination of new blood and experience
playground team members is already
showing huge promise unfortunately we
have a bit of a downer for you for this
Thanksgiving episode of GameSpot news it
turns out that gazillion entertainment
and Marvel heroes may in fact be
shutting down this Friday and not the
end of the year as previously reported
it was announced last week that the
studio behind the MMO Marvel heroes
would be shutting down along with their
game in late December but now first
reported by massively kopi comm several
employees have come out on social media
saying do zillion has terminated the
bulk of its workforce without severance
and other benefits and that Marvel
heroes will be shut down at this Friday
November 24th
PC games n have shared details from an
alleged company-wide email from
gazillion CEO David Van doorman that
confirm this saying quote the bank has
decided not to pursue any course of
action that sees gazillion meaningfully
continue into the new year and this
requires that the company terminate its
workforce the email goes on to say we
also intend to shut down Marvel heroes
Omega / the bank and marvel's wishes on
Friday November 24 2017 also according
to PC games and sources gazillion lost
their license to the Marvel properties
on the 23rd of October and their
development continued they were not
allowed to publicly discuss the matter
which would explain the company's
silence over the last month our thoughts
go out to all those affected by
gazillions closing that is everything
we've got for you today thanks so much
for joining us as always do let us know
what you thought of today's stories and
join us again same time tomorrow where
we're gonna have a chat about some of
this week's biggest stories I'm talk I
hope you see you then oh yeah finally
did it ruin practicing I and other
benefits and that Marvel heroes will be
shut down at this Friday November 24th
stop looking at me doing my weird you
keep doing lunges
PC games and have said I'm PC games in
if she had details from an alleged
company-wide email from gazillions